[Musik]
gabrielius landsbergers hat es eilig ein
Politiker in Kriegszeiten
der Außenminister Litauens fordert
unermüdlich mehr Waffen für die Ukraine
aber erst einmal stoppt ihn das
eu-protokoll und gibt ihm
Regieanweisungen für den roten Teppich
die dritte Kamera ist ihre sie können
sie nicht verfehlen der Kameramann
winken
sie können jetzt gehen
danke
[Musik]
seinen Auftritt seine Wort hat er sich
gut überlegt in Europa spürt er
Kriegsmüdigkeit Zweifel an immer neuen
Waffenlieferungen vor allem bei den
Deutschen dagegen redet er an jetzt
Imperativ es ist alternativlos der
Ukraine alle Waffen zu geben die sie
benötigt um ihr Land zurückzuerobern
Landsbergs hat uns in seiner Heimatstadt
nach Vilnius eingeladen damit wir
verstehen was ihn und viele Osteuropäer
antreibt woher die Angst kommt
als es 1991 in Litauen um die
Unabhängigkeit ging haben sie das
Parlament mit Barrikaden vor russischen
Panzern geschützt die waren nicht weit
entfernt
that direction dahinten drei Kilometer
da sind viele gestorben die russischen
Panzer überrollten die Menschen
zeitgleich hatten sich bereits tausende
vor dem Parlament versammelt
das Parlament war fabbarrikadiert
ganz viele Kameras übertrugen die Bilder
in die Welt es war klar ein Angriff wäre
ein Massaker gewesen
der Kampf gegen die Aggression der
Russen ist das Lebensthema seiner
Familie sein Großvater wie tautas
Landsbergs war damals Präsident und
führte den Widerstand an er sein Enkel
war neun Jahre alt und spürt wieder die
Angst
alle in Vilnius konnten die Panzer hören
es ist doch nur eine kleine Stadt und
die russischen Panzer sind so groß das
sind die selben Panzer die sie jetzt in
der Ukraine benutzen
wir schauen gemeinsam die Aufnahmen von
damals an vor mehr als 30 Jahren
nie wieder Opfer sein das
überlebensmotto der Litauer
wie sein Großvater organisiert er den
Widerstand diesmal für die Ukraine aber
ein Liter und glauben Sie die nächsten
zu sein
mal sehen wer der nächste sein wird denn
wir sind so nah
100 Kilometer entfernt von der
Hauptstadt Vilnius an der Grenze zur
russischen Enklave Kaliningrad
der Stacheldrahtzaun ist neu durch
Europa geht ein neuer eiserner Vorhang
der kleine Ort panemone ist die letzte
litauische Stadt vor der Grenze auf der
anderen Seite liegt Kaliningrad nicht
weit von hier hat Russland einen
Militärstützpunkt und atomwaffenfähige
Raketensysteme stationiert
Victoria palikine hält hier die Stellung
über Politik darf sie nicht reden aber
sie will uns zeigen wie nah Russland ist
da hinten verläuft die Grenzlinie genau
in der Mitte der Schnee verdeckt sie
gerade
die Brücke gehört den Russen früher
trennte Pan die mune und Kaliningrad nur
der Fluss nun ist drüben der Feind
wer verteidigt die Grenze bei einer
invasionfragen wir sie wir und dann muss
sie selbst lachen und geht zurück auf
ihrem Posten
die Grenze trennt Familien nur noch
wenige passieren sie
sie ist Litauerin ihre kranke Mutter ist
Russin und lebt auf der anderen Seite
der Brücke in Kaliningrad über den Krieg
will sie nur eins sagen
keiner will Krieg auch meine Eltern
nicht
wir hoffen alle auf Frieden aber was
können wir einfachen Leute schon machen
ein großes Set prangt seit Kriegsbeginn
auf der Häuserwand auf der russischen
Seite den Litauern macht das Angst viele
russische Panzer in der Ukraine haben
das gleiche Zeichen sie empfinden das
als Drohung
ich sehe das Z und die russische Fahne
jeden Tag das weckt bei mir sehr
schlimme Gedanken ich habe meinen
Verwandten drüben in Kaliningrad
geschrieben ob sie dort nicht einen
Protest organisieren können das Z zu
entfernen aber ich habe nie eine Antwort
erhalten wahrscheinlich haben sie den
Brief zensiert alles wird da drüben
zensiert
früher war es hier voll saßen hier
Russen und Litauer zusammen nun sitzen
hier nur noch die Polizisten und
Grenzschützer
Regina spürt die Angst der Menschen
einige wollen weg ihr Sohn lebt in
England
wir reden viel über die Angst vor einem
Angriff bisher machen wir Witze darüber
aber wir haben einen sehr guten Keller
dort würden wir uns verstecken der
Keller hat dicke Wände
zurück nach Vilnius zur Außenminister
Landsbergs die Debatte um weitere
Waffenlieferungen für die Ukraine wird
immer hitziger
Landsbergs zeigt uns sein Star Wars
Plakat Putin seid Darth Vader er Luke
Skywalker er hofft dass auch im
richtigen Leben das Gute siegt dazu
braucht es die richtigen Waffen für die
Ukraine
das nächste was wir brauchen sind
Langstreckenraketen
sie müssen die Amerikaner liefern
aber Kampfjets werden auch super die
richtige Botschaft
den Namen Landsbergs haben sie auf den
Barrikaden verewigt und den Kampf seines
Großvaters gegen die Russen zur Ehren
das ist das Erbe das ihn antreibt